in our Stillness other movements became
more palpable
for me one important clock ended up
being an individual buckeye tree in a
park that I always walk through
this tree grows leaves and flowers in
the spring and goes dormant in the late
summer but that procession is uneven
across the region across a Grove across
the branches of the same tree or across
the surface of a yellowing leaf
the body of the tree itself is also a
record of the past since the Buckeye's
ability to go dormant is an evolutionary
response to a change in the climate
three million years ago
and so I write what is a clock if it's
something that tells the time then my
Branch was a clock but unlike the clock
at home it would never return to its
original position
instead it was a physical witness and a
record of overlapping events some of
which happened long ago and some of
which are still occurring as I write
this
and that's that those images are also in
in the book this is also a text exchange
from last month when my boyfriend was
here and I was in the Santa Cruz
mountains and were observing that the
clock is the same in both places
um Okay so
what I just described is something that
I describe in the book as unfreezing
something in time I write if you want to
see some time that isn't fungible just
pick a point in space a branch a yard a
sidewalk square a webcam and simply keep
watch a story is being written there the
story is inseparable from the story of
all life even yours
and while it might be fascinating and
enlightening enlivening for us to
unfreeze things in time there is also an
ethical Dimension to doing so because to
see something as an as inhabiting time
with you is to consider that it has
experience
while researching for this book I was
really floored by a study on something
called the Lesser Minds problem that's a
what it sounds like it's a name for our
bias to see the inner lives of other
people especially people we consider to
be in out groups as not not as complex
as our own
and so in one of the experiments people
were asked to consider typically
dehumanized out groups such as drug
addicts or people without housing
ordinarily for those participants
thinking about people in those groups
wouldn't activate regions of the brain
associated with theory of mind
but what the researchers found was that
by simply asking the participants
whether or not a houseless person would
like a certain vegetable those neural
regions became activated
in other words and in my interpretation
the question about the vegetable
presumes a person with preferences and
desires and desire and attitude toward
the future and a reflection of one's
past can only exist in time the time
inhabited by that person
this notion of frozenness or unfrozeness
has broader implications namely
regarding the climate crisis that
increasingly interrupts the human
calendar
just like the concept of time as money
is a political history so too is the
division of who and who does not inhabit
time I.E who has experience and who acts
on the historical stage
the Jamaican theorist Sylvia winter has
written about how the Western notion of
man versus nature defined man against
colonized people who were characterized
as Timeless backward or less progress
part of the similarly Timeless landscape
and in my formulation Frozen
in that same book I mentioned earlier
the colonization of time the author
quotes a letter from the daughter-in-law
of a British missionary in what is now
South Africa in which she writes
you must know that today we have
unpacked our clock and we seem a little
more civilized for some months we have
lived without a timepiece John's
chronometer and my watch have failed and
we have left time and been blanched onto
eternity however it is very pleasing to
hear tick tick tick and ding ding for me
this is just an important connection
that the same framing that has allowed
us to juice the supposedly inert
non-experiencing natural world dry is
the same one I mentioned earlier in
which laborers have been Juiced of their
supposedly fungible lifetimes
it also explains why we feel that there
is cultural human time which moves
forward and makes things and natural
non-human time which is cyclical and
insubstantial it's that it's an echo of
that supposed hierarchy of The Eternity
and tick tick tick and ding ding as Bill
McKibben has pointed out the irony of
this conceptual divide is that what is
thought of as human cultural time
actually can't keep up with the changes
in what is thought of as non-human time
in that vein I argue a lot in this book
for non-human subject hood and that's
one of the reasons I Rely so much on
indigenous scholarship
like those Scholars and like McKibben my
reasoning is partly practical I really
don't believe that a true holistic
response to either time scarcity or the
climate crisis is possible without such
a change in perspective
[Music]
thank you